you can't bungle that car behind you
tell us about that concept car we're
absolutely fascinated with this car you
know it's our statement concept
statement of uh our way to enter the hot
booming crossover segment uh it's
booming you know that from the walking
around the show here but uh this is our
indication that we're going to enter
that segment and we're going to make a
statement because we maybe we're coming
to the party just a little bit late but
we're going to be noticed okay so you're
acknowledging that you're a little late
on the late to the crossover B late yeah
but we started the whole concept with r
4 but the Rav 4 grew so it's covered a
lot of markets in the rest of the world
but as that car grew we want to go back
to where Rav 4 was of course in a
different way you can see here quite
expressive I think it also indicates
that Toyota's taking a lot more risk and
uh L more exciting designs than we've
ever had in the past and AO Toyota is
behind all this pushing us pushing the
designers to make sure that we really
make a statement it's a concept car now
when might we see it on the market I
can't say exactly when give give us a
time frame well you know one year is too
soon three is probably too late so you
can start guessing 2016 you can start
guessing Okay um and then give me an
idea of how what your sales targets are
even that far along yeah so you know
we've been growing for the last three
years in a row four years in a row every
year 20 30,000 units so I heard you
earlier talk about the malaise you know
we still think that we can manage our
own business in Europe and do that well
we've been growing steadily our market
shares growing a little bit and as DDA
said earlier in the presentation we're
profitable for 2 to three years in a row
now so we run a profitable business in
Europe it's kind of unique we've got a
very high hybrid mix here in Europe
which goes counter to the normal
business well go walk me through you're
that hybrid business yeah so in the past
people said you needed to have a diesel
in Europe to succeed actually now we're
20% hybrid mix in Europe of our total
lineup if you take the cars that we
actually sell hybrid in Yus one and
three is a hybrid in AIS our our golf
competitor one and two is a hybrid so we
are extremely hybrid oriented and we
think it's the future and we're proving
that uh it's it's not quite hybrid but
it is involving two different types you
and BMW cooperating on fuel cells how's
it going I think first of all the
cooperation between the companies
culture means everything you know this
from your business reporting cultures
either work or don't work but the good
news is that BMW toota culture is very
good so that can only lead to some good
results I can't say a lot about that but
we're working on some pretty interesting
things with them okay well I mean that's
a cheese again this is I me we're an
auto show not a strip CH we got to keep
this clean but when you say interesting
things does that mean a joint produce
um I think the technology First
Technology first and then we're working
on a sports car feasibility study I
think maybe late this year early early
next year we can share with you the news
on that give us a little bit as much as
you can about the sports car sports car
is going to be ultra sexy fantastic
design you've seen some hints maybe
through some of our concepts with Toyota
before and we need sports cars in the
Toyota lineup to put that energy back
into the brand you know I was speaking
with Martin vender cord from Volkswagen
last night and I told you know Toyota's
still number one they want want to they
want to you know supplant you in that
spot you confident in your Global
position are we confident we're not
chasing Volkswagen it's not part of our
game I know this is disappointing to
your readers it's not part of our game
plan we want to make sure we have a
really strong business profitable
business and if we grow and become
number one great that's an outcome it's
kind of the end result so we want to
make sure that our company is really
solid and we expand in all the regions
of the world of course even the
difficult ones like Europe and I think
we're proving that um the most difficult
region in Europe has to be Russia what
are your forecasts Russia is going well
for us surprisingly we have a different
model portfolio than most other car
companies we have a very high-end
mainstream I would call it mix we sell
camine above uh including some strong
SUV lines our sales are only down a few
percentage points the Market's down 20
23% we've gained market share in Russia
since the crisis up from 6 and a half to
7 and A2 points and then what did 2015
Russia continue to gain the market
itself as as you know from talking to
all the executives it's definitely going
to be down to about 2.1 million is what
everyone's saying so we're going to have
to fight in a smaller pie but we're
going to try to hold our volume in the
similar level that's our goal well I
wish you the best of luck of that goal
and I hope to see this year in 2016 guy
I think it's pretty clear we're going to
see this concept car on the market in
2016 we'll fire up that work AMX and get
you one shipped over